This was such a good idea, coming to Supper & a Movie's.
I-- I feel like
I'm in Hollywood.
Yeah, but we're on
vacation in New York.
Winning.
Hey, guys!
So is that a wrap or do we
want to shoot a dessert scene?
Oh, we are so full,
we're like the Klumps.
Okay, well then,
you know what time it is.
It's...
( imitating fanfare )
No way!
You guys ready to play?
All right,
here we go.
In the movie "Forrest Gump,"
when Jenny lets Forrest
touch her,
what item of Jenny's
roommates does Forrest
ejaculate on?
( imitating Forrest Gump )
I may not be a smart man,
but I know the answer.
Bathrobe, right?
Splooge!
Ha ha, you nailed it!
Do you really think that
that's an appropriate trivia
question to ask in front
of children?
Oh, well, I know it was pretty
hard, but I mean, you got it.
Yeah, we did.
Okay, next question.
In the movie "Back to the
Future," who is the mean bully?
I'll give you a hint.
He tries to rape
Marty McFly's mom.
He's like, "You love me,
you just don't know it yet."
Yeah, oh yeah.
Come on, honey,
kids, you remember.
He's trying to rape the mom
but the mom's all upset
'cause she's trying
to sleep with her own son.
Okay, I don't want to hear
about people raping moms.
Oh, I think you
guys will remember.
It's like the hottest
scene in that movie.
I don't-- I don't actually
see what's hot about that.
Oh, you should watch
it again, it's great.
Oh!
It's Biff.
Our son's name
is Biff, duh!
What a cool name, buddy.
All right, cool.
One more to go.
In the movie "Up,"
what objects lifted
the house containing
the old man
and the young
Asian boy scout?
I know this one.
Trick question, the boy
was not Asian,
he was retarded!
Balloons.
The answer
is "balloons."
I'll get your check.
Uh, you're bumming us out,
so I think it's best
if we go to
Ground Zero by ourselves.
Jenny, Biff.
Come on.
Sorry your wife
is such a monster.
I'm leaving her.